une impression générale positive c'est
ce qui est ressorti ce jeudi à vienne en
autriche des deux heures de réunion
relative à l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien
nous sommes heureux de voir tout le
monde de retour à vienne prêt à faire
avancer nos discussions
malgré les événements et les
déclarations très difficile de ces
derniers jours nous travaillons vers le
même objectif le retour des etats-unis
dans l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
et sa pleine mise en oeuvre des
événements difficiles à un euphémisme
pour évoquer l'escaladé des tensions
autour du nucléaire iranien depuis ce
week end à l'origine un acte de sabotage
commis dimanche matin dans l'usiné
d'enrichissement d'uranium de natanz
dans le centre de l'iran or le programme
atomique de téhéran est sa principale
arme diplomatique la république
islamique n'a donc pas tardé à réagir
lorsque vous commettez un crime
nous vous coupons les mains nouveaux
coupons les demain nous coupons l'une
avec les centrifugeuses ir 6 nous
coupons l'autre avec l'enrichissement
d'uranium à 60 % 60 % un taux
d'enrichissement bien plus élevé que les
3 67 % prévus par le traité de vienne et
qui s'approche des 90% nécessaire à la
fabrication d'armes atomiques et qui
suscite de vives inquiétudes
ces annonces iraniennes sont
particulièrement regrettable à un moment
où tous les participants à l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien et les états unis
ont débuté des discussions
substantielles dans l'objectif de
trouver rapidement une solution
diplomatique permettant de revitaliser
et restaurer l'accord la communication
récente dangereuse de l'iran est
contraire à l'esprit constructif et à la
bonne foi de ces discussions
we take nous prenons très au sérieux son
annonces provocatrices d'une intention
de commencer à enrichir l'uranium à 75,1
vous dire que cette mesure remet en
question le sérieux de l'iran ce qui
concerne les pourparlers nucléaires
comme le souligne l'impératif de revenir
à une conformité totale avec l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien s'est justifié
way le président hassan rohani c'est lui
défendu de toute attitude belliqueuse
nous avons annoncé dès le début et nous
nous en tenons à ce que nous avons dit
que nos activités nucléaires sont
totalement pacifiques et que nous ne
cherchons pas à fabriquer des bombes
nucléaires
l'objectif des négociations à vienne et
le retour des etats-unis dans l'accord
que donald trump a quitté en 2018 des
pourparlers techniques se poursuivront
dans les prochains jours